so uh yeah for those not aware
this is a good mater cake defy christmas
arena
um prize fund is listed here the total
fund adds up to about
over 60 thousand dollars because bitcoin
went up today first prize is one bitcoin
i think this is probably the richest
prize fund for an online open tournament
question what would you do with one btc
i would probably
i actually don't know good luck eric do
i convert it to us dollars or dogecoin
or maybe i would buy like a
a super hot tub
i'd buy a hot tub so big that it could
fit uh more than just like one person or
give everyone in my family hot tubs
or buy some cake
so many possibilities
maybe i would let twitch chat decide
what i would do with it
i would run like a massive poll hey it's
tv yeah if i want if i win one btc i'll
get everyone in my family hot tubs how
about
i don't know whether to like warm up by
playing chess
or warm up by meditating
or warm up by turning on the heat
this is going to be insane there's so
many players
so the odds of me playing like magnus or
hicario are probably like very low
unless i do really well
i'm realizing the strategy for the first
game because i'm going to be playing
someone good the first game
i might as well berserk
try and win it really quickly
man
i'm thinking a strategy for the first
game is to try a dirty premove trick i
have an idea of what to do the first
game
but i don't want to i won't spoil it
shall i berserk or not berserk
can we run a quick poll
so for those that don't know there's
always people some people who don't know
berserking means you cut your time in
half so rather than starting with two
minutes i would start with one minute
and if i win i get an extra tournament
point
so
it's probably a good strategy in a
tournament like this if
i want to maximize
my score but it's also super super risky
pam says don't do it but 68 of people
say do it or say yes
well a poll
also this is probably going on youtube
so hello to people watching in the
future on youtube
[Music]
um i'm sorry you can't really vote in
this poll because in the future this
poll will have expired
this is also twitch chat's opportunity
to say hi to youtube for people watching
on youtube if you watch live you can
interact and chat
if you subscribe you get the high
youtube emote
if you have prime you can subscribe for
free
71 360 people
say berserk the first game
[Music]
okay
oh
my heart rate
oh it's almost a hundred
ah it's 105.
looking at my heart rate makes me more
anxious oh teotaki says i'll donate your
max heart rate in dollars
this tournament
to charity of your choice
oh that's so kind
so this is a request
to twitch viewers but also to youtube
if you see a max heart rate clip it
just so we have proof
okay good luck to everyone
it's time to focus
i'm berserking
oh no is leaches crashing
oh no
do i refresh
uh-oh
i feel like i'm witnessing history
but i could be witnessing the lee chess
version of the titanic
it's all like haru's fault
streaming only chess
it was bound to happen
the day hikaru would stream on me chess
it would break the site
was it like a master plan
oh no my bitcoin
what do we do
we broke lee chess
do i switch and late join title tuesday
is title tuesday going on right now
ouch whoever is playing title tuesday is
a really intelligent individual
okay maybe i should look at twitch chat
twitch chat says don't refresh
oh my heart rate's recovering
but no that's not good for my charity
because tiotoki is going to donate my
max heart rate to charity
i actually get it up to at least
probably not a thousand
at least like 150 would be
still healthy right
do push-ups that's actually not a bad
idea
okay i'm gonna leave stream and jump up
and down and then let's see how high of
my heart rate goes
meanwhile i'm going to
go to the place
where things crash
also known as twitter
oh no my leachats
what's the saddest emoji face possible
[Music]
that looks pretty sad
yeah twitter is the place to go and
other websites crash
but then when twitter crashes and we're
all doomed
okay so
i'll be back momentarily
wait people are playing wait what
no
ah it started
can't handle so many people sag
okay i'm not gonna be back because every
second counts
me chest is kind of back but it's still
loading
i don't know whether to refresh or to be
patient or maybe i'll open a new tab
i feel like anytime i click anything on
the site i'm breaking it more
i'm giving it more tasks to do
i'm 2000
that would be a nice feed a rating
it's officially down
server error
we expect to be back very soon
what do i do with my life now
[Music]
someone lost reading because they were
paired
[Music]
yeah i don't think their rating will be
recovered
that's not lee chess's top priority
right now
wait exercise for excuse me in a game
exercise sparks leave uh leave the link
in the
put my game link in the chat
and i'll click it
excel sparks is a mod right
yes
can i play for my phone
maybe phone will take up less bandwidth
but this is even worse than the lee
chess's down page
at least my tweet is doing well
[Music]
yeah
here's a call to action to follow me on
twitter
i'm trying to reach 57.3 followers
okay at least we have this page again
hey it's gotham chess what's up gotham
chess
wait let's watch gotham chess
twitch.tv slash
levi
can we have inception
wait gotham stress is not streaming
oh well now i feel kind of sad
oh no my gotham chest
there's a chance i might do wedding
photos for gotham chess
even though he already had a wedding
i'll do belated wedding photos
wait it's back
wait let's refresh again
the key to winning this tournament is to
connect oh it's it's back okay
ah join okay we're back
only burned hey i won the game
i've won my first game with lost the
second
who did i play
why is it all the players disappeared
oh no eighteen thousand seven hundred
fifty five players
i'm in twelve twenty two
berserking my first game
ah okay let's play this
opponent wasn't pre-moving
wait